guten abend wir sind live mit zdf heute
live weltweit hungern
828 millionen menschen alle 13 sekunden
stirbt ein kind unter fünf jahren an den
folgen von unterernährung soweit die
neuesten zahlen die hungerkrisen in der
welt werden immer schlimmer und der
krieg in der ukraine wirkt da wie ein
brandbeschleuniger vor allem eben in
afrika deshalb schlagen die
welthungerhilfe und andere
organisationen alarm warum gelingt das
nicht den hunger in der welt zu
bekämpfen und warum macht russland die
situation noch schlimmer darüber wollen
heute abend sprechen matchmaker nokia
erarbeitet beim welternährungsprogramm
im sudan wenn ihr fragen habt an unseren
gesprächspartner könnt ihr die uns gerne
schicken entweder ihr schreibt sie
einfach in den chat rein oder ihr
schickt sie uns per mail und worüber zum
bäcker materie ist in der krisenregion
dafur und dort erreichen wir ihn jetzt
hoffentlich schönen guten abend
es tut mir am tempo
guten abend
im ok es gibt viel hunger in der welt in
anderen ländern afrikas in asien im
nahen osten
wir schauen jetzt erst mal exemplarisch
nach somalia wo meine kollegin unsere
korrespondentin sand rathaus gedreht hat
90 kilometer beides problem hassan salat
gelaufen aus ihrem dorf bis in somalias
hauptstadt mogadischu hier in einem
zentrum gegen unterernährung bekam sie
endlich hilfe
ich hatte zwölf kinder vier davon sind
durch die dürre gestorben von den acht
die überlebt haben musste ich vier
zurück lassen sie sind krank diesem hier
ging es am schlechtesten deshalb habe
ich es mit genommen um es zu retten der
hunger trifft die schwächsten am
härtesten vor allem die kinder schon
eine durchfallerkrankung kann den tod
bedeuten
hilfsorganisationen warnen vor einem
massensterben am horn von afrika
millionen kinder sind schwer
mangelernährt hunderttausende kinder in
somalia
sind von akuten hungertod bedroht wenn
ihnen nicht in den nächsten wochen und
monaten geholfen werden kann grund ist
die schwerste dürre seit jahrzehnten
hinzu kommt der krieg in der ukraine
somalia bezog mehr als 90 prozent seines
weizens aus der ukraine und russland
doch die lieferwege sind blockiert die
preise für lebensmittel in die höhe
geschossen das bekommen noch
hilfsorganisationen zu spüren es fehlen
die mittel die meisten spenden flossen
in die ukraine während am horn von
afrika millionen menschen hunger leiden
wenn die welt nicht aufhört nur auf die
ukraine zu schauen und nicht sofort
handelt wird das kinder sterben am horn
von afrika explosionsartig zunehmen es
ist ein wettlauf gegen die zeit und mit
jedem tag wird die lage schlimmer
wie es die situation bei ihnen da vor
bei uns in der davor
und auch generell im sudan ist die
situation
sehr unklar und die situation sagen wir
so hat sich verschlechtert und
leider sind wir keine gute nachricht in
der zukunft weil momentan
sind 15 millionen leute im sudan die
stehen vor hunger und
in den nächsten zwei drei monaten
wie diese zahl auf 18 millionen steigern
die situation von unserer seite als die
welt erinnerungs will als als wird
ernährungsprogramm
ist sehr schwer weil die bedürfnisse für
die leute hier
ist gestiegen aber die mittel um diese
bedürfnisse zu decken sind einfach nicht
da in der nächsten helfe hälfte dieses
jahres wollten wir dringend mehr
als 370 millionen dollar um diese
bedürfnisse zu decken
shaqiri mein kollege christian volk hat
einige fakten zum sudan zusammengetragen
das wollen wir uns kurz anschauen
der sudan ist eines der ärmsten länder
afrikas laut welthungerhilfe ist etwa
jeder dritte auf humanitäre hilfe
angewiesen
insgesamt 14,3 millionen menschen
nahrungsmittel gesundheitssystem
wasserversorgung alles nicht ausreichend
vorhanden auch deshalb gehen in der
hauptstadt khartum fast täglich menschen
gegen die aktuelle militärregierung auf
die straße nach deren putsch im
vergangenen jahr wurden viele
internationale hilfsgelder eingefroren
hinzu kommt der klimawandel im osten des
landes trocknet er den boden aus lässt
ihre verdursten weniger essen mehr
menschen aus den nachbarländern eritrea
äthiopien und im südsudan fliehen sie
vor überschwemmungen und krieg in den
sudan hier in der dach region herrscht
ebenfalls ein bürgerkrieg seit fast 20
jahren millionen menschen mussten ihre
heimatorte verlassen lokale kräfte
können all diese krisen schon lange
nicht mehr bewältigen rücklagen sind
aufgebraucht und die preise für
nahrungsmittel steigen seit jahren
massiv an die vereinten nationen fordern
nun dialog zwischen allen politischen
kräften
sie befürchten ein endgültiges scheitern
des staates und eine weitere
verschärfung der hungersnot
warum hat sich der hunger bei ihnen in
der letzten zeit nochmal verschlimmert
die faktoren die dazu beitragen sind
viel oder die sind vielfältig es gibt
innere faktoren
des landes sudans und das sind
politische
sicherheitsproblemen auch luca kriege
und auch es gibt auch außen faktoren
diese außen faktoren hauptsächlich ist
der krieg in ukraine
sudan ist jährlich an nahrungs defizit
hat jährlich nahrungsmittel und da dazu
dafür muss sodann nahrungsmittel
importieren um diese defizite zu decken
und sodann importiert mehr als 50 ihre
getreide bedürfnisse jährlich und die
meisten von diesen oder bucht sich
dieser 50 prozent dieser getreide kommen
vom schwarzmeerregion und wenn es dort
krieg herrscht dann heißt es dass die
lieferkette ist abgebrochen und das
endet mit steigende
nahrungsmittelpreisen innerhalb eines
jahres sind die nahrungsmittelpreise im
sudan um
160 prozent gestiegen und das heißt die
leute die es sich nicht leisten kann wir
werden noch mehr leiden darunter und da
sind die organisationen wie
welternährungsprogramm und der
welthungerhilfe
immer da um diese leute zu helfen aber
wenn es mittel fehlen um diese
organisationsarbeit zu füllen dann heißt
es ist auch eigentlich die situation
sehr sehr schlecht für die für die leute
die das brauchen die diese hilfe
brauchen und wir haben schon gesehen ist
sind mehr als 15 millionen leute die das
diese hilfe dringend bräuchten auf den
aspekt ukraine und russland kommen wir
gleich nochmals zu sprechen es gibt hier
eine frage im chat von christian was
fehlt für die produktion im eigenen land
ist das wasser saatgut dünger was fehlt
ihnen
da konnte man sagen alles fehlt im
letzten jahr die ehre die getreideernte
im vergleich zu den vorigen jahres sind
um 30 prozent 30 prozent gesunken
das ist von einer seite auf der anderen
seite steigen die preise auf
der anderen seite haben wir noch
bürgerkriege hier im davor die situation
manchmal verbessert sich manchmal wie es
wieder schlimmer also die ist flüssig
die situation ist sehr flüssig und das
heißt dass auch die bauern oder die
hirten die kunden auch ihre ihre
produktion nicht fortsetzen wenn es
kriege gibt bürgerkriege gibt dann gibt
es keine produktion also die vertont
sind vielfältig und dazu verschlimmert
die situation hier aber die welt kennt
nur die politische situation im sudan
diese seite hier probleme dieses landes
sieht man nicht so sehr und leider ist
diese seite der situation hier im sudan
das ist die seite des
die fehlenden nahrungsmitteln oder die
idee oder die verschlechtert die
situation dies
produktion im landes ist ist wirklich
eine sehr sehr sehr großes problem jetzt
geworden und deshalb führen wir heute
abend dieses gespräch alexander fragt
auf youtube seit jahrzehnten leisten der
entwicklungshilfe was fehlt dass diese
entwicklungshilfe die situation
verbessert wird diese zweckgebunden
eingesetzt und ist sehr effizient
problem die diese situationen hergeben
sind wir auf englisch sagt man man mit
der mensch macht probleme und solange es
kriege gibt wird es immer diese probleme
geben bei
klimawandel das kann man bewältigen wenn
man die richtige strategie
durchsetzt aber die diese politische
probleme die
das ganze system destabilisieren und
werden die produktionen stimmen und dann
die und dann die resultaten von den
steigenden preisen
das ist immer das problem also wir
können
projekte durch
indien die dem zur selbsthilfe der
bevölkerung führen konnten aber wenn es
die sicherheit fehlt und auch über
kriege gibt dann
gehen wir wieder zurück das ist leider
die situation wo es ist aber der wille
dass wille der der andere der
entwickelten länder ist immer darum die
die armen ländern zu helfen um die
situation zu vermindern die präsidentin
der welthungerhilfe mal dem thema hat
heute gesagt dass der kampf gegen den
hunger auch eine frage des politischen
willens sei sie sieht zu wenig
politischen willen wie würden sie das
einschätzen
leider ist es so
politische wille ist sehr wichtig aber
fehlt das feld es gibt in einigen in
einigen gebieten wurde weder geht aber
leider der wille ist man geht vor und
dann zwei schritte vor und einen schritt
vor und ein zwei schritte zurück
und aber alles hängt an dieser
politischer wille und
wir konnten auch manchmal hoffentlich
bleiben wenn wenn wir sehen dass
gespräche die politische gespräche
geführt werden um die situation zu
verbessern dann sollten sie unterstützt
werden aber zuerst zuerst musst das
leben der leidenden gerettet werden und
in dieser ball war wenn es später
frieden gibt aber wenn es so viele leute
gestorben sind weil sie keine
nahrungsmittel hatten dann gibt das
macht das auch nicht so viel sinn sie
sagen das leiden dass das leben der
leidenden rappen lassen sie uns konkret
über ihre arbeit sprechen wie helfen sie
den menschen konkret vor ort
vor ort zuerst als
welternährungsprogramm wie erlebt wie
retten leben also die leute oder die
unterernährten kindern die tragende
mütter die nicht so gute ernährt sind
oder die leute denen es die mittelfeld
um nahrungsmittel zu kaufen
das ist das allererste und dann später
führen wir auch projekte durch
selbsthilfe
hilfe zur selbsthilfe für die
bevölkerung schaffen das sind
langfristig leute der sinn der projekten
mit langfristige
wirkungen die dann auch die 1
als haushälter ein grund führt zum
beispiel
familien mit mit
familien mit
die die keine genug mittel haben um
nahrungsmittel zu kaufen also
langfristig des sie einkommens für ihre
einkommens verbessert werden um das
selber zu beschaffen diese projekte sind
langfristig aber wie ich gesagt habe
zuerst das leben retten ciw c't und
danach diese projekte zu machen und
jetzt bräuchten wir dringend diese
mitteln um die
lebensrettende projekte durchzuführen
sonne fragt auf youtube wie viel von den
spenden geht an bürokratie drauf also
was wie viel wird dafür investiert und
was kommt bei den bedürftigen an
bei den bedürftigen ich konnte sagen
mindestens mindestens 70 prozent kommt
der mittel kommt an den bedürftigen weil
über die zeiten sind die lieferung
skaten oder die die prozessen
sie haben sich verbessert leider in
dieser situation heute wo die
nahrungsmittel gestiegen sind und auch
die preise für benzin und diesel
gestiegen sind steigen diese mittel um
die nahrungsmittel zu beliefern also zum
beispiel zu transport die kosten sind
gestiegen
und was heißt das dass das muss man noch
mehr mitteln spenden um die
nahrungsmittel zu oder irgendwelche
hilfsmittel zu zu den bedürfnissen zu
bringen leider ist die situation die die
situation so und das macht unsere arbeit
auch nicht leichter nicht leichter weil
auf der eine seite die bedürfnisse sind
gestiegen aber
die mittel dazu fehlen um die kosten um
die mitteln zu zu zu den bedürfnissen zu
bringen sind aufgestiegen das ist eine
ganz gerne ganz prekäre situation aber
das leben muss weitergehen und die leute
musik geholfen werden
es gibt noch eine frage von sven gibt es
irgendwelche technologien die dabei
helfen könnten sich selbst zu versorgen
und ob die vorenthalten werden
ja die namen das ist eine ganz gute
frage weil wenn man die situation zb in
der vorsieht
es wird gekämpft hier
hauptsache um land oder wasser
diese ressourcen die wachsen nicht aber
die bevölkerung wächst was heißt dass
das heißt es muss eine anderes denken
hier eingesetzt werden was heißt dass
das heißt wenn ein hirten zum beispiel
100 kamele hat und diese kamele die
werden nur vielleicht die gehen ihnen
nur sagen wir so 40 liter pro tag von
milch dann sollte es das geändert werden
dass dieser hatte ihr braucht nicht mehr
braucht nicht alle die 100 kanäle
sondern der konnte nur 20 kamelle halten
dazu brauchst braucht er weniger land
weniger weine aber wenn diese 20 kanäle
mehr milch produzieren also das ist eine
eine 1 1 denken dass man nicht von heute
auf morgen durchführen kann aber das
sollte eingeführt werden und die gleiche
methoden oder das gleiche abrollt auch
für pflanzenbau durchführen um die
produktivität zu erhöhen damit die leute
in der zukunft die mehr produzieren aber
auch weniger land mit weniger ressourcen
und mit weniger weniger mit wenigem
wasser und so weiter und so fort die
produktivität zu sehr jungen und werden
auch hoffentlich auch keinen kämpfen um
diese diese ressourcen land und wasser
die es nicht wachsen oder nicht so viel
davon geblieben ist weil
klimawandel haben ein negativer effekt
auf lan auf wasser hat
wir haben eben schon über die ukraine
gesprochen dass eben durch die
verknappung des weizens der preis massiv
gestiegen es lassen sie uns noch mal
kurz auf russland schauen russland ist
sehr aktiv im sudan warum ist das land
so interessant für präsident putin
diese frage ist eine ganz politische
fragen und
für uns als
welternährungsprogramm wird wir sind
teil von der vereinigten nationen
wir
machen keine politische kommentare das
land also da ist ein reiches land
ist hat die möglichkeit sich zu
verbessern will es die richtige politik
hier durchgeführt wird und auch die
richtige mittel eingesetzt werden um
diese entwicklung zu fördern und das ist
was man heute braucht so dann braucht
nicht so viele nicht so viel weltpolitik
und so warten ein dann braucht zuerst
frieden und dann die produktion kann
weitergehen oder kann kann sich
fortsetzen
dann stellen wir vielleicht noch mal zum
schluss die frage dass es ja eigentlich
gerade die völlig absurde situation gibt
dass die spendenbereitschaft in der
zivilbevölkerung
extrem hoch ist das geld aber bei ihnen
nicht ankommt wie kommt das zusammen was
muss sich da ändern
die spenden ist immer willkommen von den
leuten von den von den regierungen
meistens von europa von deutschland von
amerika von japan von saudi arabien
ich bin gekommen sind immer willkommen
und weil uns in welt er
welternährungsprogramm die spenden
kommen was uns gegeben wird das wird
auch weiter zu den bedürfnissen gegeben
werden und nur ein kleines teil so
ungefähr 7 prozent das wie benutzt und
diese mittel zu den bedürfnissen zu
bringen und das ist ein 1 1 das ist
etwas woran
welternährungsprogramm über jahren
gearbeitet hat und bei uns wir sind froh
dass wir sind einer von den besten
organisiert organisationen die mehr als
am wenigsten die am wenigsten spenden um
hilfe zu den bedürfnissen zu bringen
vielleicht letzte frage die vereinten
nationen haben sich vorgenommen den
hunger in der welt bis 2030 zu beenden
dass es jetzt gar nicht mehr so lange
die zeit wird langsam ein bisschen knapp
oder
ja das stimmt leider aber wir sind immer
sehr hoffentlich und positiv das ist
dass dieses ziel erreichbar noch
erreichbar ist
dabei mit der koalition dass die
richtige politik das durchgesetzt wird
entweder die auf der politischen seite
oder auch von der klimaveränderung
bekämpfen das müssen ganz richtige
maßnahmen durchgeführt werden damit das
klima nicht weiter verschlechtert aber
auch wo es gekämpft wird das muss
stoppen das muss kämpfen muss in davos
stoppen das geld muss in in jenen
staaten die sich die unsicherheit in
somalia muss schlucken alles damit ist
so zur vernunft kommt kommen dann wollen
wir positiv bleiben aber in der
gewissheit dass auch sehr sehr viel
unternommen werden muss um den hunger in
der welt zu stoppen im ok ich danke
ihnen ganz herzlich für das gespräch
alles gute und
ich bedanke mich auch ganz herzlich bei
euch dass ihr euch unseren stream
angeschaut habt und zu eure fragen
vielleicht noch mal zum schluss der
hinweis wenn ihr den menschen in afrika
helfen möchte das aktionsbündnis
katastrophenhilfe hat ein spendenkonto
eingerichtet mit der bahn de 6 5 104 106
100 104 106 100 stichwort zdf hunger in
afrika am besten schaut ihr euch das
noch mal in ruhe unter spenden punkt
zdf.de an danke und ich wünsche euch
noch einen schönen abend